hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to flashing lights which is
a police fire and ems simulator
i'm going to try the ems simulator
because i've tried the other two in
various other games
but i have yet to try to save people's
lives with a
uh with an ambulance besides uh surgeon
simulator but that was many years ago
and that didn't go out so well
no i'm ready i'm not saying this is
going to go well
but i've grown as a person
max vehicle traffic 5 max pedestrian
parked vehicle density i can't seem to
change
oh yes i can max 99
12 max 99 20
okay i'm day friendly friendly fire
with my fire fuel consumption uh sure
i actually um like most games don't know
how to play this one
but i'm gonna try really hard because i
keep going into these and they have so
many complex controls but i don't know
what i'm doing half the time but this
time
i'm gonna do what needs
to be done which is save lives also
apparently there's a multiplayer version
of this
okay medic i want to get people
up off the ground i want to save lives
my name is
done no my name is mine my name
is uh i have no name
you need me my motor kits
bam okay cool hat
okay glasses
nice face mask yes
ah nope responsible i like it done
well the glasses kind of clip in was it
really only like one option
i don't want anyone yeah
like i'm overriding no
serious business uh yeah that's fine
okay good
my name is not important i'm a faceless
nobody but i save lives i'm a hero
actually i'm a hero i really hope
someone's not gonna be dying right off
the bat
okay here we go emergency medical
services dispatch vehicle incident at
address screen
tag two vehicle collision call id for
okay
okay wow that is sensitive controls
oh
all right okay
turn down my mouse sensitivity okay
let's
yes i missed it by that much that's okay
i still need to get familiar
all right so it's a nice town we got
mega cola
we got louis vuitton tvs
stop and boobs okay
unconscious person yes
player 205 a4 like i said name's not
important
left mouse button left mouse button yes
yes yes yes i'm already way ahead of the
other games that i had before because
i'm in
the car it turns on
i love it this is intuitive control
this is intuitive i'm intuited
i'm in tuned okay green okay i see the
green dot
[Music]
oh we're gonna say how do i turn on my
lights
[Music]
all right let's turn that off um i
missed my turn hang on
wait
[Music]
what is that what is that it's a toy
if you hear this coming down the way and
you're injured you are about to die i
oh sorry hang on
[Music]
okay hang on where are you oh i see
unconscious person okay
you're gonna be fine i'm here let me
just back up to you
yeah one sec
all right yeah all right how do i get
out
uh left click so easy so easy hey what's
up hey
how's it going what is up how are you
uh interact with a med bag right med bag
med bag okay med
bat med bag med bag med bag
med bag okay i'm inspecting you look at
your head
you got a nice head on you not breathing
no pulse unconscious oh god
oh god are you dying this is my
first oh this is my first possible bone
fracture no pulse
okay this is a problem we need to get a
pulse going
this person needs a pulse do you have
spare pulse right click to stop
inspection
perform super remove top part
okay why okay close off perform
cpr i don't think my hands should be
going
through your chest sir but
i did it defibrillator
do i have that don't mind me stepping on
you it's fine
uh trunk uh items ah no no
no no no no no no defibrillator
you get defibbed okay we need to
put the ecg leads on doink
doink doink oh we got a pulse
you don't need to be shocked do you
good cause i'm not gonna do that all
right fracture kit
uh you got some broke bones there buddy
you got broke bones all right uh cancel
that
wait oh removal okay
i'm gonna put this away seems like seems
like i could have
done this all like at once and it would
have been a little more efficient but
whatever
all right you got that broke bone
nice now you
i don't request for transport or grab
stretcher i'm gonna i'm gonna deliver
you myself
i always finish the job that's what i do
professional
it's just how i am let me get this
oh man i'd degrading gta rp as a
medic med man med man incoming
med man all right you ready for some
you get get in come on
hop up and hop up hey dude you're gonna
help out or something just come on just
kind of heave home i'll grab his broken
arm you grab his legs
and we'll just kind of
walk all right thanks dude i did it all
myself
all right
[Laughter]
i love how intuitive go around all right
whatever i'm gonna close this up you
good there
you go yeah you're good you're good
close that up let's get to the hospital
that's me running all right
by the way is this the uh the
ambulance drop off or what
do i drive in do i go do i go in
do i gotta go in doesn't seem to be
anybody in there
i don't know about this i don't know
about this place guys i don't know about
this this
doesn't seem right but all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna get you into the the haunted
building
with nothing in it don't worry bud
you're gonna be just
fine in you go
i did it oh my god another day
another job well done i have officially
hospitalized one
person i don't know if i should be proud
of that but boy howdy am i
man what a day what a day my dudes what
a day let's turn those lights off we
don't need him anymore
i get a left turn signal right turn
signal
emergency lights awesome
what a good day vehicle incident driver
trapped
i'm on the job where is it where where
is it
where's oh no
i didn't lose any reputation for that
noah because no one saw it
respond code three i don't know what
code three means
does that mean lights on yeah you better
get out of the way yeah you better get
out of the way
you better get out of the way this is my
turn it's my turn
not that turn i need the other turn man
when we drive back from whatever this
incident is
this guy is going to have quite the trip
didn't lose any reputation i can't hear
a goddamn thing
in fact i might have gained reputation
from that because i'm just so
cool uh hey what's up guys what's up
inspect the person okay uh just gonna
warm my way here
all right good stuff good stuff good
stuff turned on my right blinker but
that's okay
all right not you oh ma'am
ma'am oh boy well
if only i had help but i don't but it's
okay ma'am
you okay looking at your face
breathing pulse found conscious possible
neck okay neck injury that's no good
that's no bueno we don't like that
okay pulse found right arm okay you got
pulse but you might have a
neck problem uh neck collar do i have
that here
okay uh neck collar boom
okay neck collar is on there okay we're
gonna go for a ride
okay hop in well yeah i i do this a lot
i'm a professional you guys see my sick
drift
tricks you impressed pretty cool right i
drift with this [ __ ]
yeah not bad anyway stretching eight
how do i stretchalize you hang on let me
move my med bag out of the way
okay put this back in the oh man being a
medic is so hard
here we go and you're in
perfect i'm uh reverting my eyes
in there all right you ready all right
we're going
hey what's up weird triple vans
i'm sure you're up to no good how did i
turn my blinker on
oh oh here comes another one
yeah that's not concerning oh there's a
van that got in the accent oh another
van
oh good what's with the white vans all
right anyway lady
lady lady hold your neck hold your neck
lady oh no
i will not be thwarted by one single
barrel i will
not and we're good and i even reset it
damn i'm good am i going the right way i
hope so
do not you you you go to the right i go
left around you i am not wrong in that
all right lady hold on to your neck
because it's about to get some whiplash
in here
sorry all right so how you doing
uh you having a good day i mean
obviously not but you know yeah
you uh you from around here you you just
visiting
you uh deliver what are you delivering
in that van it's very strange actually
that
so many people have those white vans
anyway we're coming in hot and heavy
a little reputation loss but hey i've
got plenty you
are gonna go into the fun building it's
a very fun building trust me it's a very
fun building
uh it doesn't seem like a lot's in there
but that's just your neck telling you
lies so don't lie
to me and i won't lie to you all right
let's let let let
oh let's go okay hang on one second
oh that's worse uh let's go
let's go and you're gonna
and you're in there all right cool all
right well this is actually a well put
together game you know what that this
this actually gives me hope
that if i go and do the fire fighting
one i'm actually going to be able to
fight a fire
all right so i don't want no car
accident i want like a
10 alarm fire that's what i want all
right what do we got what do we got what
do we got
perfect big man all right oh yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah now we got it oh hey cool
nice nice change roll change roll oh
i i could have just changed roll oh okay
select vehicle um
oh well that's not what i'm looking for
come on what's that all about
yeah yeah that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about where is
it vehicle ready but where
but where is it garage there she is
there she is my beaut my beautiful baby
now this is a beautiful baby all right
all right vehicle incident nah nah nah
skip
skip skip we are not looking for no
vehicle incident we want the big fire
okay i don't know how to open the doors
all right we're kind of trapped oh boy
do i get out and push you to butt
door okay push the button okay all right
cool
vehicle fire nah no vehicle fire i want
the building fire
big building give me big dildo i'm a
huge build-up
now any minute now there's going to be
ho
a conflagration vehicle is
no i don't want a vehicle instead come
on
arsonist ooh arsonist you say
well looks like some arsonist's ass is
about to get blasted full of water
we're about to shove a hose so far up
them that they
it's fine fires put out 15. oh [ __ ] that
sounds like a lot of fire unless it's
not excuse me
pardon me gotta go up this windy road
i'm sure this is meant for
trucks such as me lights on horns on
nice not as nice
[Music]
what is that
[Applause]
there we go that's more like it okay
get out of the way man this road huh why
the artist arsonist have to do it so
high up
look who lives up there god damn nice
view oh never mind
there's a horrible fog rolling in that's
going to destroy everything
and i hit the only tree in the area god
damn it
what's happening i hear something
oh my god i hate oh oh no
please no no no no
no i'm turning right and yet i go left
what what is happening there's an
arsonist
there's an arsonist there's a noise
what is happening okay
all no we're right it
and now we are meg okay stuck on that
yield sign yeah that makes sense
get out of the way my dude get out of
the way
i believe there's a shortcut here
fine oh no are we stuck again oh
no oh no oh
no no please
and we're on it i think i still think it
was shortcut
all right i've only burned up 10 of my
gas shortcut
all right i'll never learn my lesson as
far as i live
as far as i live not as long get out of
the way
my god my dude my dude get out of the
way
dude get out of the way
all right arsonist here we go we're here
who could disturb such a peaceful abode
arsonist my ass all right what do i do
um okay uh uh
okay vehicle that's if i wanted to
clamber in but i don't
um trunk here we go uh fire uh
water hose
attach
yes yes yes what happens if we run out
of water what oh
ah oh oh oh uh huh
oh yeah oh yeah baby
oh yeah okay all right
hell yeah okay all right okay all right
hell yeah i feel like i might run out of
water before i
solve the problem but uh
uh oh here we go there we go found it
you gotta detect it it
only kinda wants to wash oh you gotta be
efficient about it ah i wasn't being
efficient
okay nice
any other fire do i gotta go in perfect
perfect
this is much less thrilling than i had
hoped
boy howdy this is um
i don't know how they made putting out a
fire boring but they sure did
and i am out of water no water supply
okay that's good i guess um
i'll go in manually
it's it's the same it's the same
i got it guys don't worry this fire's no
match for me
uh okay so this game definitely ain't
that game that uh bob wade and i played
uh that had the thrilling action of
fire putting out i don't even get to go
in do i
i'm not even gonna go into this thing am
i no i'm not
the thing is i i'm not gonna do that
when i'm out uh
okay well you know it's half done it's
half done
do i have a fan what do you want
fan for we'll just get some air on this
bad boy
oh okay it's gone it's just gone good
scuba
scuba okay i'm going in
i'm going in
i can't well i'm on fire oh my god i
didn't know i could catch on fire
okay there's gotta be like a supply hose
um
so supply hoes from what i remember from
the other games
uh maybe here-ish uh
maybe in the back
out rig oh
oh oh oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
well that's just going to take forever
to get done i'm not going to do that
use ladder okay i'm on the ladder
use ladder i'm on
well i gotta go back down
i'm not quite at the fire okay let's
drop her down a bit
yeah yeah that's the extent
let's suck that back in there and put
her down a bit
perfect all right let's get a nice
flambe on me
all right use ladder
i'm coming don't worry
i made it well
we sure did our job here how do i return
it to its original position
maybe we could drive with it up it might
be fun
i think that might be it oh yeah it
looks good
all right let's get up there is this no
it's still shaky
he's just really nervous about heights
is there fall damage in this game
[Music]
cannot use this seat while using scuba
okay
put the scuba away scuba away
all right let's get out of here job well
done gang job well done
all right don't worry guys i know a
shortcut somehow i don't think this is
going to be a problem
lovely day for it have fun you're
welcome we'll build you
excuse me oh sorry oh
drifting is a little strong
all right gang don't worry i think this
thing actually stabilizes us
all right i believe
don't worry don't don't worry
don't worry i know a shortcut oh
no oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no
my shortcut no my shortcut no hang on
oh god please my shortcut
oh no
[Music]
well well you know how this goes we'll
just call tow truck and take care of
that i can make it down
manually where did all the city go
what happened while i was away what
happened
oh i can't jump i can jump wait could i
not jump before i thought i could jump
man that jump is not okay that jump is
not okay
city's changed since last i went up this
hill
dare i try the police dare i
to try the police dare i to this is not
[Music]
i said boarded up why is every window
boarded up something's not right here
something's going on here
okay i'm gonna try here we go you're
good i'm just gonna go
oh hey what's up register suspect ooh
[Music]
oh is that my vehicle
oh yes please yeah i feel the power
already
why is it a toy car arse no i'm not
responding to no
arsonist get out of here just gonna go
cruising around
let's go yeah this is some pep oh yeah
who cares about my
reputation i'm part of the police you
think we care about reputation
oh you watch yourself
damn look at me go look at me go
damn shoplifting unacceptable
yes there shall be no oof
there shall be no shoplifting in my
city okay arrive on scene talk to staff
find shoplifter and arrest them return
sterling goods
perfect all right all right who's here
hello was it you you the person did you
do it did you
you did you do it watch yourself you
freaking watch yourself dude
you freaking watch yourself oh hi
shoplifter
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow holy [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay wait do i have uh oh oh my god okay
uh
weapons uh get number two weapon got it
all right
you watch a shotgun very accurate
very that's what you get
well i guess all in a day's work
i suppose i can't exactly return the
goods cause it's
just a horrible incident of twin
brothers in
trouble you hate to see it you hate to
see it
i'll leave this for the ems to clean up
i suppose
well job well done
[Music]
i'm out of here okay
so that was flashing lights there
definitely was a lot of flashing lights
honestly not bad really truly
not bad pretty damn good actually uh
well okay not pretty damn good but way
better than all the other ones that i've
tried so far
it had a complete experience i'm still
messed up by that twin brother incident
man
that's going to haunt me on me for a
long time but thank you everybody so
much for watching maybe i could play
this
multiplayer i don't know if i'd have the
will power to do that but you know
like could be fun who knows so let me
know down in the comments thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you